ich bin wirklich sehr gespannt wie so
oft wirkt einfach so kann offen sagen
ich habe schon mal gekifft also ich weiß
wohl wie das ist dann so in dem fall
manchmal etwas geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video heute
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut hast du
ganz kurz bevor ich weitermache ich muss
erstmal hier das licht noch heroin so
ein bisschen so ein bisschen grüne
atmosphäre
jetzt sieht man dass das jetzt also
werde ich jetzt leicht angespannt oder
und hierzu ruhige musik warte mal und
moment so ist doch gut oder
so ein bisschen nebel noch der
durchzieht das ist einfach sehr sehr
entspannend hier heute nein leute spaß
beiseite
ihr habt wahrscheinlich im juni schon
gelesen um was es heute geht ich habe
hier ein wunderschönes kleines paket
bekommen und in diesem paket sind wohl
einige hanfprodukte also produkte die
cbd enthalten kann abi die ol also es
nichts mit thc das wäre ja in
deutschland auch nicht legal aber ich
muss trotzdem sagen ich bin super
gespannt was mir geschickt wurde und wir
testen das heute einfach mal auch hier
ihr könnt als erstes rein gucken ein
bisschen stroh oder was ist das hier ja
das passt ja auch ganz gut
also wir haben hier zwei zettel das ist
das ist ja gleich überall bei mir im
raum
dann ist nicht aus cd ja mir wurde hier
folgendes geschickt und zwar von hand
geflüstert
einmal cbd öl nochmals dwdl
und dann haben wir hier noch cbd honig
okay jetzt sind die überall schon diese
stroetinga vielen dank das war es auch
leider schon mehr war nicht drin
aber ist ja besser als damit also ich
muss sagen ich habe so was noch nie
probiert
ich muss auch erstmal mich so ein
bisschen informieren weil um ehrlich zu
sein ich bin kein profi auf dem gebiet
ich will ja auch nichts falsches sagen
und so das gute ist wir haben hier schon
mal ein anwendungs abc von hanf
geflüster und da steht eigentlich alles
drin anwendungs empfehlungen bla bla bla
und hier haben wir noch hey alex deine
hand geflüstert team wünscht dir viel
spaß mit unserem cbd will da flüsterte
ich doch mal zurück hier vielleicht mal
ganz kurz kanada wie die otc anna
billionen ist ein nicht psychoaktive
cannabinoid aus dem weiblichen han es
sind entkrampfen de entzündungshemmende
angstlösende und gegen übelkeit
gerichtete wirkung beschrieben weitere
pharma biologische effekte wie eine
antwort dann ist mir schon wieder zu
viel fachchinesisch alter wer soll das
denn verstehen ob hinein ich habe schon
zum großen teil verstanden und was auch
noch dazukommt wollte ich euch hier
einmal zeigen hier sind ein paar punkte
aufgeführt cbd anwendungsgebiete ich
glaube das größte ist erstmal
schlafstörungen deswegen nehmen dass
sehr viele menschen schmerzen übelkeit
stress perfekt für mich eigentlich
blutdruck depressionen entzündungen cbd
führt ihre haut und krebs also zum teil
echt schlimm it themen oder sachverhalte
zu denen das angewendet wird und heute
halte auch hier in meinem youtube-video
jetzt schauen wir uns das doch mal an
weil das ist jetzt nicht so klar ich
probiere es jetzt gleich aber ich glaube
das muss man auch verteilt über den tag
nehmen empfohlene anwendungen fünf
tropfen ca 0,2 millimeter entspricht 10
milligramm cbd zweimal täglich in die
mundhöhle zum beispiel unter die zunge
tropfen und 60 sekunden einwirken lassen
die steht das gleiche drauf wir
empfehlen einer dosierung von zweimal
fünf tropfen täglich dabei raten wir
zunächst mit einer geringen dosierungen
anzufangen und sie gegebenenfalls zu
erhöhen
bis die gewünschte wirkung erreicht wird
genau also
diesen produkten ist kein thc deswegen
kann man das einfach im alltag benutzen
ich bin echt super gespannt also ich
werde euch heute abend dann davon
berichten wie es mir so geht und ob mir
das immer so ein bisschen versüßt hat
sah ich war heute ich bin wirklich super
gespannt wie siehst du auf mich wirkt
einfach so kann offen sagen ich habe
schon mal gekifft also ich weiß wohl wie
das ist dann so in dem fall
manchmal malta das ist aber nicht so
einfach heute dieser honig der riecht so
kastner honig dass könnt ihr euch nicht
vorstellen
und vielleicht auch ein bisschen nach
rast richtig ganz gut wir haben gerade
morgens das schmerzt einer schönheitskur
ist blass doch einfach mal damit
anfangen oder eine wohn ich finde ich
super lecker als ich an sich schon gerne
habe ich früher aber meiner oma gegessen
so ältere menschen haben eigentlich
immer hohen oder die ersten viel honig
ne ich glaube schon dass die ältere
generation mehr honig ist als die
jüngere generation mal schauen ob ich
meiner oma hier dem cbd und wohne ich
dann auch empfehlen kann wobei meine oma
mir dann sicher sagt cbd so löschzug
dann nämlich gar nicht die hatte letztes
mal seine op und dann hat sich
schmerzmittel bekommen und dann hat sie
gesagt ich nehme jetzt tilidin wird mir
cdh ich kann okay wir probieren jetzt
mal diesen honig inhaltsstoffe bio
blütenhonig und 300 milligramm cbd
extrakt
[Musik]
ok also ich muss sagen super lecker
geschmeckt wie honig hat mir sehr sehr
gut geschmeckt also das ist richtig
richtig guter honig es hat aber halt
auch nur nach honig schmeckt also man
hat er da jetzt nicht noch irgendwie ein
komisches den geschmack oder so ich hier
auch einfach mal davon aus dass die
menge die hier drin ist auch nichts
gegen das ist was ich dann jetzt gleich
ein lebe also wir haben hier nämlich
jetzt einmal fünfprozentiges cbd ich
hoffe das sagten so falls nicht
korrigiert mich gerne in den kommentaren
und zehnprozentiges cbd jordan vor doch
natürlich war das stärkere oder wir
wollen ja auch irgendwie eine wirkung
spüren die sind auch gar nicht mehr so
günstig das zehnprozentige kostet 60
euro und davon kann ich mir jetzt
einfach mal fünf töpfen rein wirkt alles
sehr umweltfreundlich muss ich sagen das
paket diese sachen hier das jetzt aus
holz wieso nasentropfen alter das
erinnert mich wirklich daran früher
hatte ich auch immer solche nasentropfen
abfahrt oder also was soll ich jetzt
noch das umlagern letzte glaube einfach
unter die zunge und 61 sekunden
einwirken lassen sich nach seiner mine
montieren
so das war's dann auch schon ach so
einwirken lassen ja jetzt hab ich schon
halb runtergeschluckt dann wird ja nicht
so schlimm sein oder mich ich sag jetzt
einfach mal einer minute nichts besser
ok ich glaube die minute ist und wir
haben jetzt gleich 12 uhr ich bin auf
jeden fall verabredet zum mittagessen
ich muss jetzt gleich zu meinen eltern
fahren dann habe ich heute noch einige
sachen freundlich erledigen muss wo ich
auch ein bisschen unter schwestern
vielleicht stehe deswegen sehen wir uns
dann heute abend wieder
ich nehme das dann so um 19 uhr einfach
nochmal geb euch dann ein kleines fazit
dazu und ja dann bis später fängt der
tag heute entspannt an leute was geht
wir haben jetzt schon kurz vor setzt das
erste mal habe ich im alten reich
eingenommen ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
ich würde jetzt lügen wenn ich sagte er
ich hab da war schon voll die krasse
wirkung und so ich denke man muss es
dafür einfach über einen längeren
zeitraum einnehmen
ich hätte auf jeden fall richtig gerne
noch mehr hand produkte getestet war er
da war der an sich nur drei stück drin
vielleicht fertig das duo einem zweiten
paar könnte ja sehr gerne kommentieren
was ich dafür stellen soll aber ich
werde jetzt auf jeden fall noch mal die
fünf tropfen nehmen hier moment
es schmeckt übrigens ein bisschen so wie
gras riecht könnte man ja das kommt
schon viel zu tun was ich aber schon auf
jeden fall sagen kann und das mache ich
auch ernst das ist eigentlich ein
bisschen relax macht also man ist ein
bisschen entspannter gläubig aber sonst
hatte ich überhaupt gar keine wirkung
ich werde das jetzt mal vielleicht im
nächsten tag auch noch ein bisschen
weiter ausprobieren und wenn sich
irgendwas weltbewegendes tut werde ich
das euch noch mitteilen aber was jetzt
da war ganz lustig mal gucken habe ich
in vier fünf stunden gut schlafen kann
ich werde berichten danke fürs zuschauen
wir sehen uns morgen 19 wieder und wenn
ihr jetzt schon mal genommen habt könnt
ihr einmal kommentieren ob wir das gerne
in dem wozu wir das nehmen und ob ich
das weiter nehmen soll oder auch nicht
keine ahnung ich bin sehr gespannt auf
eure meinung haut rein abonniert sehr
gern den kanal bis morgen